I know that you hear a lot about shadow
banning D monetization there are a lot
of chicken littles out there but I do
want to at least inform you in case this
channel goes away for good as to why and
as to just how easily possible it could
be for us to be gone from YouTube
tomorrow we've received what could
potentially be three hard strikes so we
have a screen shot here for one parody
video the dr. Trump music video that we
did in the span of a week and unless we
come to terms with YouTube and the
corporate overlords YouTube rules say
that three strikes get your channel
removed now I want to be clear I'm not
exactly sure in this instance if it
counts as three strikes or just one
since we use this same video three times
in a commercial break we have half-asian
level Richmond attempting to establish
communication with them III don't know
exactly hopefully we can work it out I
want to make clear here this is
completely a parody under the umbrella
of fair use we have some some b-roll
here we do say we actually created the
track from the ground up with a project
file that you guys can see we went and
we created this entire music video from
scratch this wasn't just we didn't just
take a karaoke track and by the way it
has to be comfortable enough to the
original to be a parody there are
channels that subsist on parodies alone
and right here I can actually see an
example of Jimmy Fallon did a Bernie
parody Old Town Road side-by-side with
ours look they have a 30 million dollar
operating budget a million ours is you
mug club so I want to be clear this
might not be an exact example of an
instance here of anti conservative bias
okay but when you pair it with
disproportional targeting targeting of
the rest of our content for being quote
what they term now on the border and the
issues of notifications have been
happening the D monetization
specifically targeting our opinions as
unpopular speech at least in Silicon
Valley when you act when you take this
the toe tap the culmination it renders
us unable to create a show for you and
it'll keep columns where the channel
will cease to exist now what we do here
is very different as is our relationship
with with corporate censorship take for
example take for example let me give you
an example pure comedy channel out there
that only does the occasional parody
yeah you know this kind of thing would
hurt them it would suck wouldn't be
debilitating take more conservative
leaning channels
that maybe they've seen some radical
demonization based on a point of view we
know that happens quite a bit but one
that doesn't do comedy it'd be hard but
they can find other ways to generate
revenue let's think of a channel that
has 50 million subscribers and they find
out that the notifications like ours are
broken or that YouTube changed an
algorithm to throttle their organic
search views or related content views it
would suck not be crippling but we
experience all of that and we experience
it daily and even more the rules keep
changing YouTube claims that there isn't
an anti conservative bias that they want
to have conservatives on the platform
but that they want to encourage a
healthy discussion ok I want to take
that at face value but they D monetize
and restrict the change my mind videos
genuinely here's a question to you this
isn't a victim complex we're trying to
play by the rules let me ask you
something if a conservative cannot
create a long-form unedited no profanity
civil dialogue segments like change my
mind without being punished
how can conservatives create content for
YouTube what content could possibly be
acceptable I'm trying to figure it out
and it's been a tiring week and this is
why Mudkip is more important than ever
you can join up at lot of credit calm
slash mug Club support the show you get
access to the full daily show not
broadcast on YouTube you get this
wonderful girthy hand etched mug and the
entire blaze TV catalog in lineup and
it'll allow us to continue to trade this
kind of content regardless of
monetization on YouTube and equally
important it allows us to fight legally
to change these draconian rules which
hurt not just us and not just
conservatives but independent creators
and it's also it allows us to continue
to change people's minds on YouTube by
allowing us to throw caution to the wind
and monetization uploading anyway we
don't care we don't care if we're
monetized or not because we're monetized
by you that's how we have a parody
that's better than a 30 million dollar
operating budget no offense to Jimmy
Fallon
but that sucked and right now by the way
where for the next went four hours are
offering at $20 off to anyone who joins
just enter in the promo code a lot of
clutter that comes stuck with the promo
code I think is 2024 everyone number to
zero for everyone or listen this the
alternative you don't join up this show
as you know it I would we no longer be
able to produce it we've reached a
crossroad unless people join
mug Club we can't do this show these
segments on YouTube or any platform sure
listen I could lay off the 15 people
staff and crew and just talking to a
camera without any sketches any parody
satire on location videos changed my
mind or even so much is ever addressing
a controversial issue I could do that
but that's not the show that this crews
worked so hard to create for you and
you've made it clear that it's not the
show that you want from us and you made
it clear not just to us but to YouTube
and that's equally input that's probably
more important you've made it clear to
YouTube that this is the content you
want and it's not a violation of any
rules that's not what we set out to do
and I know people often say we hear this
a lot like well why don't you just
upload your stuff to 2-bit shoot or
insert any other streaming site of the
day here and we can and sometimes we do
as a safety but it doesn't help us in
any way create content going forward
that's like telling someone who's
consumer electronics were banned from
stores well you can just you just give
it away at a flea market I we could the
only way this continues well we're right
now we're standing the barrel of three
potential copyright strikes hopefully
half-asian lawyer does what half asian
lawyer does but you can help by joining
up at mutt club we created deliberately
by the way to not be a patreon at PayPal
or GoFundMe a lot of people so why don't
you do patreon or you know when all of
the Conservatives were doing that we
pointed out it's just rattling a tin cup
on another big tank platform and they
can give you the boot and as we've seen
now they are giving many conservative
voices the shaft mug Club is something
that we created to be completely
independent totally immune to the
censorship and I'll say it deceptive
trade practices that you see from big
tech we've partnered with dozens of
other conservative voices so we can
hopefully make it financially viable for
decades to come I know some of you have
been on the fence and $7 a month is is
not nothing I get it
but also it's been a worrisome time for
everyone involved here at this show when
you when you wake up and find out oh
crap three hard strikes our channel
could be gone within ten days and it's
particularly accelerated in recent
months after the Oscars livestream and
you know what we all know here we've all
accepted that it's going to get worse I
promise you this you join up at mug club
you support us I we all of us here will
continue to create content for as long
as humanly possible and continue to
fight these rules and the oppressive
corporate
overlords until our coffers are
completely empty for years this channels
been up for years we've we've done it
exclusively because of you and going
forward we can't do it without you okay
there if you like this video this is the
part where I would usually tell you to
subscribe but I can't do it anymore
I'm gonna tell you to subscribe and then
YouTube is going to decide that we can't
reach you even though you subscribe to
this channel and then I'll say hit the
notification bell and then the
notification Bell won't even be there
anymore I don't know what to say more
than likely you'll find my face in a
milk carton but do what you can to stop
it it's just it's just it probably won't
do much